bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous en retard et couacs à répétition on
en parle depuis le début de cette
émission communication désastreuse
emmanuel macron se met-il en danger dans
sa gestion très incarnée de la crise
sanitaire
oui clairement il a choisi cette voie
étroite
il n'a pas voulu re confiné quand les
autres partenaires européens confus mais
parce qu'il prenait au sérieux le vario
anglais et que dès décembre il savait
que 6e varions commencé à comment
arriver sur les territoires et bien ce
serait à très difficile de gérer mais
mme alleva kron a dit non nous
attendrons nous verrons on est toujours
dans la tente avec beaucoup de semaines
de retard
nous ne faisons pas de séquençage très
peu de traçage l'application stocks au
vide est un fiasco et la gestion
également incarné par mâcon comme vous
le dites est un fiasco mais pas
seulement avec lui regardez le cas
astrazeneca la vaccination qui
commençait à peine s'arrête parce
qu'effectivement ce vaccin poserait
question et des questions il y en a avec
ses thrombose veineuse rares qui ont tué
des personnes jeunes qui ont reçu le
vaccin et aujourd'hui on voit bien que
la défiance est revenu que les gens
rechignent à accepter cette vaccination
avec astrazeneca et puis il ya l'omerta
des dirigeants européens qui se refuse à
dire que la commission européenne a été
un fiasco
dans cette centrale d'achat des vaccins
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui la pénurie est
partout en europe
également en allemagne ou dans d'autres
pays
donc on est là dans un moment terrible
de d'une femme un système où à la fois
les dirigeants nationaux mais les
dirigeants européens
aveuglé par une certaine idéologie qui
leur empêche de commander des vaccins
par exemple de spoutnik vais à la russie
on voit attendre avril avant de voir ce
qu'il va se passer
le vaccin chinois également eh bien nous
sommes en europe dans une pénurie totale
les médecins les syndicats de médecins
urgentistes le disent et d'autre
emmanuel macron lui a choisi pire encore
d'être celui qui est l épidémiologiste
en chef celui qui dessinaient tout en
conseil de défense exceptionnelle c'est
lui qui donne les arbitrages finaux et
c'est lui qui pique des colères noires
comme un mauvais manager qui accuse les
rangs subalternes de faire n'importe
quoi alors que les rangs subalternes ne
font qu'obéir aux ordres du patron et
c'est lui le patron
donc je pense que oui effectivement
cette gestion enfantine irritante et
totalement in
nature de la crise va lui coûter très
cher et nous coûtent également très cher
parce que on ne parie pas avec la vie
des français comme il l'a fait sortie de
crise
imaginez bien il ya deux scénarios
possibles
il ya le scénario optimiste ou de cerio
pessimiste voire tragiques alors on va
commencer par le pire le scénario
tragique
imaginons que le vaccin fonctionne qu'on
reçoive suffisamment de doses et qu'on
est les 30 millions de vaccinés avant
l'été comme promis par le premier
ministre jean castex
alors on serait vers le retour à la
normale et puis le déconfinement
arriverait seulement là arrive le
problème de la dette la dette
kovy dans ce plan de relance qui est
finalement un plan de soutien à une
économie à l'arrêt parce qu'il ya une
mauvaise gestion sanitaire est là que se
passe-t-il et bien ce serait des
faillites en chaîne qui auraient été
simplement retarder un chômage de masse
rendu encore plus délicat par la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui continue même
si elle isabelle borne est à l'hôpital
la réforme de l'assurance chômage est
bien est revenu sur la table en disant
nous devons continuer cette réforme
donc on serait avec davantage de
français sous le seuil de la pauvreté
c'est déjà un français sur six qui est
sous le seuil de la pauvreté cette année
ça pour être davantage
compte tenu de cette gestion calamiteuse
de la crise alors ça c'est le pire mais
il se pourrait que l'on choisirait quand
même un plan de relance économique en
soutenant la consommation
ça ce serait éventuellement à un moyen
d'aider les entreprises qui retrouverait
un peu d'air avec des français qui
consomment
mais ce n'est pas le choix qui est fait
par les effectifs aujourd'hui non le
choix est à la fois de faire de
l'austérité et de faire du ruissellement
à cette stratégie qui ne fonctionne pas
en donnant de l'argent à ceux qui en ont
c'est à dire soutenir les banques les
investisseurs en pensant que vont créer
de l'emploi et eux vont permettre de
soutenir l'économie
là c'est tout faire pour empêcher le
rebond économique pourtant appelée de
ses voeux par et bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie et là ça pourrait
être une catastrophe avec non seulement
une crise sanitaire mais en plus le en
même temps un des manuels macron une
crise économique est là pour 2022
évidemment ce serait impossible pour me
répondre de défendre son bilan
le scénario optimiste ce serait que les
vaccins arrivent fonctionne soit
suffisamment nombreux que la reprise
reprennent comme annoncé par bruno le
maire à 6 % 1 même si c'est un voeu
pieux avant le deuxième semestre
donc c'est loin on serait après l'été
dans tous les cas le bilan sanitaire lui
est catastrophique
80 % de hausse de consultation
psychologique pour les moins de 15 ans
de nombreux suicides j'attends d'avoir
les chiffres sur la vague de suicides
l'épidémie de suicides qui arrivent en
france des dépressions massif chez les
salariés et puis le bilan quand même de
nombreuses pertes d'emplois parce que
les entreprises ne peuvent pas planifié
nous n'avons toujours pas de date de
réouverture pour de nombreux secteurs
qui ont fermé à cause de cette crise
sanitaire
vous avez évoqué la présidentielle de
2022 est emmanuel macron peut perdre
tous et paris y compris cette
présidentielle à la défaveur de
l'épidémie oui clairement
mais la cour est joueur on l'a vu c'est
comme ça qu'il a gagné d'ailleurs en
2010 est aidé par certains médias qui en
ont fait un champion démocratique
inconnu
aujourd'hui on le voit que c'est paris
n'ont été que une succession d'échecs ou
de dangereux paris effectivement qui
n'ont pas réussi à rendre le pays
meilleur ou ou plus agréable ou même sur
pour de nombreux français il y a ajouté
à la crise sanitaire
une crise sécuritaire terrible peu
importe les gesticulations de gérald
darmanin à l'intérieur on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la france craint beaucoup
au niveau sécuritaire comme au niveau
sanitaire
donc on voit bien que échec sur échec m
le maquereau n'a pas réussi à convaincre
n'a pas réussi à montrer qu'ils étaient
ceux dirigeants de start up nation
capable de lancer la france sur les
rails de la modernité et jean castex ce
premier ministre choisi pour être le
nouveau de paratonnerre après edouard
philippe
et bien ce paratonnerre est épuisé il ne
fonctionne plus la cote de popularité du
président est au même niveau que celui
du premier ministre que celle pardon du
premier ministre tous deux ont la
défiance des français à plus de 60 70 %
dans cette gestion de crise donc c'est
une bérézina total je ne vois pas
comment emmanuel macron pourrait se
représenter avec un tel bilan sanitaire
économique
il ya bien bien sûr un jeune une
solution qui est un plan pour sorte
d'aider les jeunes à entrer sur le
marché du travail sinistrés mais je ne
pense pas qu'il sera suffisant
il ya aussi cette volonté idéologique
car de continuer avec la dette sociale
française et de faire que cette dette
soit partagé par les plus pauvres de ne
pas faire payer les plus riches alors
qu'eux-mêmes joe biden et nos états unis
lui pas faire payer les entreprises qui
font beaucoup de profits et les citoyens
américains les plus riches et plus
fortunés ce n'est pas là encore une fois
le choix des manuels mâcon dont je ne
vois pas comment lui pourra faire
barrage comme il le souhaiterait en 2022
face à marine le pen aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment prématuré de parler de la sorte
et on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs toute la stratégie de
l'exécutif des meubles macron c'est de
séduire une partie de l'électorat des
républicains et même des élus des
républicains les faire venir et
finalement dissoudre la république en
marche pour en faire un autre parti avec
cette partie de la droite qui pourrait
l'aider à surnager dans cette gestion
calamiteuse
alexis avant 2022 il y à d'autres
échéances électorales des régionales
notamment et la république en marche ne
semble pas en très bonne position région
loin de là on l'a vu d'ailleurs lors des
municipales la république en marche a
fait 2 2 % des votes donc c'est une
gifle électorale cinglante pour les
régionales tous les ténors de la
majorité ont décliné l'offre d'être
candidat dans les grandes régions jean
michel blanquer air préfère rester à la
tête du ministère de l'éducation
nationale et gérer les clusters dans les
écoles plutôt que de se présenter pour
gagner une région pour la perdre plus
tôt et d'ailleurs la république en
marche est en train de se diluer comme
je le disais d'essayer d'effacer les
logos de la république en marche sur les
papiers de faire des alliances à droite
avec les républicains mais aussi
d'essayer de garder le modem même si
beaucoup d'élus centristes préfère aller
par exemple en région parisienne avec
valérie pécresse et préfèrent aller là
où ça va gagner clairement la république
en marche aujourd'hui est un label qui
fait perdre donc je ne vois pas comment
ce serait possible pour le parti
présidentiel d'avoir un score honnête
heureux pour les régionales
ça risque d'être encore une cinglante
défaite qui ne présage rien de l'eau
pour 2022 même si emmanuel macron veut
se poser en candidats du dépassement
c'est à dire être au dessus des partis
être ce président qui a été courageux
dans la crise
finalement non je crois qu'il a été
irritant dans la crise il a été mauvais
dans la crise son premier ministre
également et cela sera sanctionné dans
les urnes il en est conscient c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça je crois qu'il a
repris le contact avec edouard philippe
le maire du havre qui était son ancien
premier ministre et qui serait une sorte
de plan b resté fidèle jusqu'au bout
pour reprendre le flambeau d'un ni
droite ni gauche en 2022 quand la
candidature d'emmanuel macron sera
impossible compte tenu de son bilan
merci alexis pour l'un et aurélie sur rt
france